[Risate]
mamet e nokia la nokia sembra boccalon
mannoia così procreativo della luce alla
fine del tunnel ma noi anche quella
vorrei spegnerla o conosco un rimedio
dimostra meno se siete stanchi di questa
noia che pisa che abbiamo li metto
stancanti per la vostra staccate noi ma
soprattutto siete stanchi di fare le
solite cose che vi consigliano di fare
per passare il tempo come provare per 30
volte a fare lo stesso balletto siamo su
tik tok e perché no magari darvi al
giardinaggio è morta da sette mesi e
ogni tanto cerco di resuscitarlo
annaffiando di quello sputo è come
parlare al telefono con i vostri cani
sono solo al mondo sto fingendo oggi vi
mostreremo cinque giorni cieli da
cellulare che vi aiuteranno a
sconfiggere la noia
seguitemi partiamo col primo gioco che
mi ha fatto conoscere te da air lower
game queste capito che cos'è questo è un
gioco ragazzi bellissimo ok riesce a
dire qualcosa in più
ad esempio facciamo un esempio perché
era non so se canali è un gioco che ti
spinge a cercare di capire quale tra due
cose che ti vengono mostrati gli anni
cercate di più su internet si hai
ragione non è che senti più
specificamente quadro chiaro e allora
abbiamo tottenham hotspur e tim berners
lee byrne una scuola di calcio
ok apple watch di più che erano nemmeno
letto alan patrick di meno
ti prego è infatti che al 34 mila sempre
secondo il questore rimanenti smettere
di più sicuro che sarà un punto di più
aborigeni equa gli aborigeni io dico di
più sparata verso sta a me comparti
posso vincere
e vabbè allora io come bel grazie
sistema solare o il tizio di prima senza
ombra di dubbio vincesse stanno solo
sawyer sarò facili se va in una roba
cinese secondo me potrebbe anche esser
cercando di più non posso perdere
baidu ed è così con 2 milioni e due
adozioni obeidi secondo me meno
addizioni adozioni sì c'è chi meno di
barney e vai tu come in pareggio
wordpress o adoption cazzarola però
bacini se pure qua
faccioli gran gol e famosissimo e cinese
perché sono evoluti scritta british
arways wordpress e mezzo perché ci sono
quasi quindi è giusto mio blog
esatto come fare il nero ansia e
insonnia
siamo lire per me chiaramente 1 pareggio
ma cos'è priest impress e cos'è ha le
tette
beh ragazzi le tette di e che lo ho
perso con le tette non vedere una tratta
84 contro 8 prima marshall vince
gianluigi posso dire una cosa se giocate
anche voi mi lasciano tutti quanti link
qua sotto tra capisce 6 st campo il
vostro punteggio vediamo che cosa
dovrebbe fare il secondo giochino si
chiama quick drop google ha praticamente
come tu devi fare è disegnare una parola
e il computer
indovina pian piano quello che stai
facendo io vado
ci sono giocatori aia quindi si
avvantaggia battuto leader è una nostra
bagna veloce eccedenza seconda no non ci
credo ce la fa ce l'ha fatta
sì paese cos'è il 77 applicato al solito
telefono giovedì 27 gianluigi aveva
attivo hayden no perché in questo no
sono le pinze e allora dovrei
ricominciare per avanti già in italiano
vuol dire ciotole di pasta oppure che
questa vada letta p
cosa ti stipendi pa non quello che pensi
tu c'è quindi noi ha capito dove ho
indovinato ben visibile qui sorgono
scisso è però che le porgo era molto
similare anche quella sulla quale bhatti
calik udine come faccio a saperlo un
cappello che cilindro al contrario
ecco lo sapevo non ci credo le ami
quanto non azzeccate diamante bravissimi
ce l'hai fatta
con questo qui hai fatto 3 su 5 perfetto
camera il suo ciclo lo scoiattolo e con
questo la teca va no dai ragazzi questa
sera gandino a questo qui è un ching
infatti questo qui entrando questo con
la chiave vabbè dai legali della è una
zona chiave chiesto massacro prince
pantaleo che lontano da ragazzi dillo
che un complotto animo migrations fra
tutte bluetooth e v l'azzeccato non sono
affatto fatto due nuvole l'altro oceano
5 su 5 alle complimenti complimenti dai
terzo giorno pari a questo con un po
piccante ma il molto divertente ragazzi
cercheremo di renderlo il più se
possibile per permettervi di giocarci a
casa sulla sessione maggiorenni e si
chiama fashion o no
popcorn how che ti fanno vedere dei
pezzettini di immagini e voi dovete
capire se appartengono al mondo della
moda
forse appartengono invece a un mondo
digitale un pochino più se devi riuscire
a beccare il più possibile se nel
fashion fashion fashion anche questo no
ragazzi ma non sono fashion queste cose
beh direi pop corn se l'accordo non me
la sera fashion yachts maxi forte questa
qui si può cioè si avrebbe capito questa
fashion queste fashion secondo me ne sto
perché ha tutte a macerare per forza
questo e fashion
no sta guardando alle 8 40esimi auto su
40 è non so riad alla fine mi sono
fermato prima dai tocca a te ragazzi vi
prego se li fate questi giochi cambiati
sui vostri punteggi a fini di supplico
allora questa è senza ombra di dubbio
fashion fashion vault senz'ombra di
dubbio non li dire se non si capisce il
times non difficoltà
ok ci siano amici così emesso me so
fashion
questa è una battaglia di stanchezza e
pop corn esattamente star wars capitano
10 tu sei perche un doppio o guarda che
mi sa che ti ho demolito
c'è una risoluzione troppo buona per
questa foto secondo me questo corbezzolo
e sul fashion tu con questa faccia
giusta a questa è la classica stretta 9
tutti tu sei fashion era e basta
tu mi mette in crisi fashion non è buona
40 è difficile 40 impossibile fashion
anche qui mazza che alcuni sto quasi a
noi hanno chiuso una bianchina ma ho
sbagliato 2 a 1 signore mi ha fatto
tredici mammamia stracciato in questo
momento di gioco
guglielmo saldi sotto del sottoscritto
quarto gioco un po se i ragazzi però su
quelli che fanno più ridere c'è la
possibilità però di giocare una versione
un pochino più visiva e spinta sono
invece che quale giocheremo a noi che è
una versione safe con sinceramente
preferisco specialmente qui dobbiamo
riuscire a capire se queste persone
stanno suonando la batteria o stanno
vivendo un momento di fortissimo piacere
vado io a c'è pure il tempo o con tanto
di audio e vediamo di lettere l'audio si
no hanno poi ancora scoramento non sto
dicendo cosa sto votando non sempre
domande queste parole di lo che cosa
scritti perché se no sto cliccando un po
tutto tra ming in questo momento tu cosa
faccia sbagliato
ho perso quante ne ho fatte otto su
dieci provale questa felicità ragazzi è
infatti se vince andiamo un pareggio è
lei ti vogliono far credere qualcosa ma
in realtà sta suonando è invece in corso
rola tu hai una faccia di un host anche
il capello di noi sta suonando
chiaramente capello lungo biondo così
spero che non sia la sua espressione de
lise questa dico felicità sta suonando
stupido io in questo gioco ci sono delle
vite ok
ecco era molto chiari le hai perso
quanto molto su dieci quindi c'è un
pareggio qui un punto a testa che
diciamo 3 a 2 ma ci sta sarà l'ultimo
gioco a decretare o un pareggio finale e
poi la tua vittoria non so se avete
presente l'incerto de luca il presidente
della campania che diciamo si è fatto
molto conoscere in questo periodo come
quelli che sono i suoi video legati alle
sue opinioni sulle persone che non
seguivano i decreti hanno creato un
gioco su di lui si chiama de luca ram
penso io e tocca per iniziare no io sono
morto appena arrivato conte cile normale
fuga
stato contagiato di questa regione
piemonte e può stilare il comizio con
del suo aspetto
tornano i fischi
sì ma superato sì non si apre con questo
schema schedina cos'è successo cento è
il vecchio se dall'alto come un falco 6
mascherine mai se ne ha scritto a
prendere le cose carine con ti uccido
quinta mascherina pareggio bonus game
il firmware fermo dopo una lunghissima
ricerca e siamo riusciti a trovare un
gioco che mi rende felice si chiama zio
fester dobbiamo stare giocando
prendi il telefono da jurman requisito
cioè come a scuola
esposito scilla distanti di rozzano
lericini dicevo noi ci troveremo
all'interno di una specie di google maps
e vede più uscire a capire in che parte
del mondo 6 il parto io allungo telefono
colpevole deve arrivare quesito perché
si può giocare solamente una volta al
giorno quindi impala mezza minesto
giorno un centro di coppa sono in mezzo
al nulla a questo è ovvio
l'ance niente sono in molise e rami
l'america del nord verso una mamma e
attinà di punti una zona boschiva
inghilterra
a un in sudafrica è difficilissimo e
acquistiamo veramente molise quali
bayamo tutte citarmi un altro gioco ero
in america di poco perfetta non sbaglia
consenso prezzi vicinissimo ci sono
andate siamo in nuova scozia al quebec
ha messo una piece taglio il problema è
che lui non ne ha azzeccata una
eppure io non ne azzeccano una quindi
servirà un altro spareggio non è un
gioco molto divertente di trenta questo
gioco mi rimangio tutto come materia
ragazzi datemi retta se siete annoiati
non seguisse delle pecore sun in
sardegna dove siamo a berchidda a
risparmierà vicinissimo ho fatto 6.750
punti in totale
bravo gianluigi gratuito momento col tuo
telefono perché qua non si possa fare di
una volta nella vita proprio aggiorna
una crema devono far pagare tutti i modi
in queste case di legno chi è che usa il
legno aspetto secondo me a parte
geppetto roba da california per vedere
che marche sta macchina che marca e
stamattina si sono macchine americane
famosi tali non era facilissimo questo
rischio di famiglia o dalle case di
legno ragazzi classe di cemento e non
vuoi guardare tra loro mio braccio
l'individuo forse che chiaramente
americano immagino che una pescheria qui
io stavo di mezzo delle terre brulle e
appunto qui siamo in europa c'era un
ente ai 7 anni
cacchio no turchia analogia rabon
pugliesi stime a caso e climatico
mi sto cercando di mettermi fretta
perché vuole vincere questa giornata è
chiaramente luciano pagina di annoiarti
non fate come per troppe canada ci va
molto vicino
vado a vedere un attimino io adesso
clicco al centro dell'africa in modo
tale che così se la copia è un pochino
esalta troppo centrale per madonna
proprio dall'altra parte del posto
questa è l'italia c'è scritto poste non
ci credo perché beccato poste e francia
vicino questo hai fatto a 2620 vinco io
dice sponsorizzato così è possibile
tomtom invece fatto negare la challenge
control a bordo la vince la noia perché
mai mi sono annoiato vinco io comunque e
mi raccomando ragazzi link qua sotto di
tutti quanti giochi
occhio a quello che avrebbero detto non
tutti possono essere giocati a tutti
quanti ma grazie a un pubblico adulto
mi raccomando condividete con noi i
nostri punteggi su instagram pagando me
o gianluigi co entrambi sarebbe ancora
io noi gli mandiamo un bacio grandissimo
e ora vado ha ammesso il serio ragazza
selezione dall'oriente 0 con papa prega
per può ogni gioco è riuscito pian piano
ad alzare l'asticella della depressione
e a togliermi un pezzo di felicità un
pezzo di cuore
c'è chi può mordere inoltre lo ior non
ha ristorato ogni giorno arcus prende un
pezzo della tua anima
la creiamo qui ci vediamo domenica con
la puntata di cui c'è la puntata ciao
ciao
per questo è un insegnamento
insegnamento anche meglio passare il
tempo insieme invece che allenarsi con
dispositivo un bell'insegnamento ea fare
il quale diventa parte di quei giochi